hey guys do you know what kind of food
you need to eat to increase your
metabolism
it is important because if you know what
food to eat then it will be easier to
control your body weight as well so in
this video i'm going to give you the
eight best foods to eat that will boost
your metabolism let's not waste any more
time let's get to it
[Music]
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're here my name is daniel
and welcome to the men's lifestyle where
we cover a lot of interesting topics
fitness grooming style and life itself
especially the deep
truths of life important stuff that guys
need to talk about we cover it here on
dealing men's lifestyle so if you
haven't subscribed yet please consider
it and then also click that notification
bell so you won't miss any of our future
videos now let's get to those metabolism
boosting foods number one
eggs they are for me the best source of
protein that you can get well that is of
course after whey protein and they're
low in calories as well they have a lot
of b vitamins which of course help with
your metabolism
why because b vitamins have to change
the food you eat into energy
[Music]
jelly peppers if you love eating spicy
food as much as i do this is just a
bonus a study published in the journal
bioscience reported in 2017
that capsign which is an active compound
found in chili peppers helps to speed up
metabolism
and of course it might also help in
weight loss as a result
beans
you guys know all those jokes you hear
sometimes about beans right like
what happens when you eat beans with
onions
cheer guys
you get it cheer guys
anyway
beans are good for your metabolism and
they also contain a good amount of
protein and amino acids
whole grains
you know i still don't i just don't get
it why do people still eat those refined
unhealthy grains you know white bread
and white pasta it is so unhealthy for
you they basically contain empty
calories no fiber and they can also
cause your blood sugar to spike unlike
whole grains they are so good for you
they actually boost your metabolism
because of the fiber and it's also
anti-inflammatory
[Applause]
spinach
what do spinach have in common with
shellfish beans and lean meats
iron now iron is important because it
carries the oxygen that your muscles
need to burn fat but now just be careful
don't eat too much iron because that has
been proven to be linked with heart
disease in men
[Music]
water but not any water here not those
purified water that you find in some
countries like china today
but mineral water
you know
when i was young we used to be
able to drink from rivers here in south
africa we had clean lakes clean rivers
these days you can't do it
what has become of the world i don't
even want to think about my
grandchildren what the world is going to
be like you know these people who just
don't care about the world around them
anyway let me just continue before i
start to work myself up the swiss
studies showed that purified water does
not boost metabolism in men but mineral
water does
coffee you probably know this already
but did you know that coffee is the most
psychoactive substance in the world the
caffeine in coffee works great to
increase your metabolism and that is
also of course why they included in most
fat burning products today
t
you know most people they trust green
tea to give them that uh metabolism
boost that they need the weight loss
everybody know how good green tea is for
you but oolong tea is actually better
that is of course when it comes to
metabolism a study from japan showed
that green tea only packs half the punch
that oolong tea does
now just a bonus tip for you
if you stick to foods if you only eat
foods that will always promote and
preserve lean muscle mass
then it will always help to boost your
metabolism so at the end just maintain a
healthy lifestyle now if you want to
know what food you need to eat to
increase your testosterone you can watch
this video here and you might also like
this one here now always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys